Robb Stark: The ascension of Aegon Targaryen
was confirmed; and the fate of the Seven Kingdoms,
sealed, on the Field of Fire.
Kings Loren Lannister of the Rock and Mern
Gardener of the Reach stood against Aegon's
invasion.
They commanded a united force of 600 banners,
5,000 mounted knights, and 50,000 men-at-arms.
Aegon's host was vastly outnumbered, and when
the army of the two kings charged, the invaders
turned heel and ran.
But Andal might was no match for dragon flame.
When Aegon unleashed all three of his dragons,
4,000 souls were horrendously burned alive
on the battlefield, King Mern among them.
Realizing all hope was lost, King Loren surrendered.
The Starks of Winterfell had no intention
of submitting to Targaryen rule.
They had reigned as Kings in the North since
the days of the First Men, and were determined
to resist the Targaryen invaders, just as
they had resisted the Andals thousands of
years before.
King Torrhen Stark led his army to the Red
Fork just east of Riverrun, hoping to succeed
where Loren and Mern had failed.
But when Torrhen saw the size of Aegon's now
mighty host along with his monstrous dragons,
he knew he couldn't subject his followers
to the horror of another field of fire.
He bent the knee and swore fealty to Aegon,
who allowed the Starks to maintain their lordship
over the region as Lords Paramount and Wardens
of the North.
Without question, Torrhen Stark saved thousands
of lives that day.
He was ever after known as "the King Who Knelt".
Jaime Lannister: For thousands of years, the
Kingdom of the Rock ruled the Westerlands.
When the ironborn became a nuisance, my ancestor
sailed to the Iron Islands and returned with
a hundred ironborn hostages, promising to
hang one from the rock every time the ironborn
dared raid our shores.
The ironborn stayed away, well, after twenty
or so.
When the Andals arrived after sweeping across
the rest of Westeros, we invited their sons
and daughters into the rock as squires and
court ladies.
I don't think we ever had to hang any of them.
Finally, Aegon the Conqueror defeated us on
the Field of Fire, and my ancestor knelt.
Still, little changed but titles and taxes,
for when Visenya Targaryen saw the rock, she
gave thanks that my ancestor had met Aegon
on the field.
Even dragon flame would have washed over the
castle like the waves and left just as much
a mark.
Randyll Tarly: Most of the Great Houses spout
such nonsense about their origins.
At least my family doesn't claim some long-lost
ancient crown, like the rest of them.
House Tarly breeds soldiers, not kings.
When House Gardener ruled the Reach, we served
them well and loyally.
When House Gardener died, and Aegon gave the
Reach to their stewards, House Tyrell, we
served them well and loyally.
We know our place, even if the Tyrell women
don't.
When Aegon's son faced rebellion from the
Vulture King of Dorne, my ancestor, Savage
Sam Tarly, led the royal forces on a Vulture
Hunt.
Heartsbane, our ancestral Valyrian sword,
and the pride of our House, soon ran red from
point to hilt with rebel blood.
Brynden Tully: Men have fought over the Riverlands
since the Dawn Age, but that's to be expected
of things that rest below the Neck.
Doesn't help that the Riverlands are between
everything and everything else.
The Westerlands' gold, the Reach's grain,
the Vale's rock, and the North's... snow?
House Mudd once ruled as the Kings of the
Rivers and Hills, but after a thousand years,
their line was exhausted and fell to the Storm
Kings, who fell to the ironborn.
I suppose after years of drowning at sea,
our rivers looked pretty attractive to that
race of pirates.
Never mind that their monstrous castle, Harrenhal,
was too large to staff and garrison.
It turned out the ironborn would not be there
long enough to bother.
Aegon Targaryen landed to our south and, as
had many before him, liked the look of the
Riverlands.
My ancestor Edmyn Tully led the desertion
of Riverlords to his cause and was rewarded
by getting to watch King Harren burn in his
own tower.
Unfortunately, that's not all Edmyn got.
House Tully was named the Lord Paramount of
the Trident, which means we had to keep in
line all those lords who hadn't governed themselves
for thousands of years.
Yet under the Targaryens, the Riverlands knew
a peace we hadn't had for centuries, if ever.
But like all good things, sooner or later,
it all goes to shit.
Theon Greyjoy: When Aegon and his dragons
burned Harren the Black and all his sons at
Harrenhal, the days when men feared the sight
of our longships were over.
Aegon would not permit marauders and raiders
in his Seven Kingdoms.
With Harren died our empire and the Old Way
that forged it.
But what is dead may never die.
Petyr Baelish: Impregnable.
That's how the Vale sees itself.
Shielded from Westeros by its mountains.
Except the Vale has been conquered.
Those vaunted mountains didn't stop the Andals
who came by the eastern sea.
The people of the Vale say that Ser Artys
Arryn, the Andal general, flew on the back
of a giant falcon and slew the Griffin King
on top of the tallest mountain.
During Aegon's conquest, one of his sisters
did the same, flying a dragon over the Bloody
Gate and up to the Eyrie, the Arryn stronghold.
And the Arryn boy-king yielded the Vale in
return for a ride on the beast.
Do you sense the theme here?
The rationalizing of defeats with mythical
beasts and the whims of children, instead
of acknowledging the root cause – the arrogance
of isolation.
Brienne of Tarth: The first Storm King, Durran,
started his reign by declaring war on the
gods themselves.
He loved the daughter of the sea god and the
wind goddess, but they forbade the union.
At their wedding, the gods unleashed their
might, pulling down his hold and killing all
of Durran's family and guests, though his
wife shielded him.
Durran vowed to rebuild, and when he did,
the gods again destroyed his home.
His councilors begged him to retreat inland,
but he would not abandon his war.
Finally, with the council of the Children
of the Forest, or perhaps a young Bran the
Builder, Durran raised a seventh castle that,
try as they might and still do, the wind and
sea gods could not tear asunder.
Durran took the name Godsgrief and called
his new home Storm's End.
Having beaten the waters to the east, the
Storm Kings turned their gaze to more practical
enemies, the Reach, the Riverlands, and Dorne.
For thousands of years, the Storm Kings fought
the Gardener Kings of the Reach and various
families of Dorne for control of the Dornish
Marches, just below the Red Mountains.
The fighting did not stop until Dorne married
into the Seven Kingdoms, a mere hundred years
ago.
But still, the houses of the Stormlands, such
as the Dondarrions, guard the Boneway, the
mountain pass into the Marches, against any
Dornish incursion.
The Storm Kings had greater luck to their
north at first.
They took the Trident from the River Kings
and built an empire that stretched as far
as the Neck.
But then the ironborn swarmed out of their
islands and pushed the Storm Kings out of
the Riverlands.
No doubt, the ironborn intended to expand
their empire into the Stormlands.
Before they had a chance, Aegon Targaryen
landed with his dragons.
While Aegon burned the kings of the Iron Islands,
the Rock and the Reach, his fiercest commander
and rumored bastard brother, Orys Baratheon,
set out to subdue the Stormlands.
No matter how fierce a warrior he was, no
one could have envied his task.
Storm's End had seen thousands of years of
war and never fallen, but Argilac, the Storm
King, chose not to barricade himself behind
its walls and gave Orys the battle he must
have hoped for.
Orys slew Argilac and took Argilac's castle,
kingdom, daughter, sigil, and House words.
House Baratheon became the Lord of the Stormlands.
Viserys Targaryen: The Targaryen dynasty united
the Seven Kingdoms and lasted nearly three
centuries.
It was a dynasty forged in fire, sealed in
blood, and destroyed by rebellion.
The Targaryens are blood of the dragon, descended
from the nobility of ancient Valyria, a once-mighty
empire in the east.
When the cataclysmic Doom laid waste of Valyria
and its people, the Targaryens survived, having
settled in the island fortress of Dragonstone
years before.
They remained there for a century until the
rise of Aegon the Conqueror.
Instead of attempting to reclaim the eastern
lands of his ancestors, Aegon sailed west
for the Seven Kingdoms, his sisters Visenya
and Rhaenys at his side.
To keep the bloodlines pure, Aegon continued
the custom of his Valyrian ancestors and took
both of his sisters to wives.
Together, they came ashore on the eastern
coast of Westeros.
Their blazon: a dragon with three heads, representing
Aegon and his sister-wives.
Their words: "Fire and Blood."
While their host was small when compared to
the armies of the Seven Kingdoms, Aegon and
his sisters had a secret weapon.
The last of the dragons.
He conquered every kingdom, save Dorne, which
eventually bowed to Targaryen rule a century
later.
He had the swords of his enemies melted down
by the fiery breath of his dragon, Balerion
the Black Dread, and forged into the Iron
Throne.
The capital city of King's Landing was built
on the eastern coast, where Aegon and his
sisters first came ashore.
And Aegon ordered the construction of a royal
castle on its highest hill, the Red Keep.
For three hundred years the Targaryen dynasty
stood strong, in the face of rebellion, civil
war, and plague.